foreign
Utah what's up Matthew
hey Dr Dean my heart is racing
[Laughter]
Kelly doesn't even have a heart man so
it's all good just kidding hey you're
good man what's up
uh well I'm calling because I'd like to
figure out why the repression of my
self-expression causes me distress
tell me more
yeah so I I wrote a script to organize
some of this
um and it ended up being kind of like a
journal entry it definitely stopped me
or slow me down if uh if it seems like a
lot but we're gonna keep it nice and
light hold on hold on
all right
how off the rails are you willing to get
oh we're going all the way okay we're
gonna get way off the rails so
I can tell 13 seconds into this call two
things
you are so good at repression
and you're very very smart
sophisticated even
and whatever your repression is about
has been something that you've gotten so
good at navigating
that you've created poetry and flowers
all around it
so I'm gonna challenge you I don't want
to hear your diary I want you to say it
in one sentence my name's Matt and
here's what I'm wrestling with
my name's Matt and I'm wrestling with
a lifelong repression of myself
Matt you're still doing you're still
doing it you almost got there and then
you chickened out all right let's try it
again I'm Matt and
I'm Matt and I am a lifelong liar
keep going
what are you lying about getting myself
away from everyone in my life
um just about everyone in my life uh
specifically as it relates to
cross-dressing okay
hey I want you to go backwards and own
it for a second okay
can you do that
absolutely
because we can't get anywhere if Matt
doesn't like Matt
yeah there's a lot of self-hatred there
I can feel it all I can just feel it I
can man
and if we were sitting right here the
fir I would stop all conversations and
I'd give you a hug
I appreciate it okay you would have to
buy the beers but I'd give you a hug
just kidding I'd probably have to okay
two two people two guys having nachos
all right
the way you introduce yourself is I'm a
lifelong liar the way I introduce you
introduce yourself is I'm a lifelong
theater performer I'm a scam artist
and I disagree
often
when we have things that we don't want
to tell anybody about
our immediate childhood environment says
if you say this out loud it's going to
get you killed
it's gonna get you hurt these people are
Gonna Leave You
and so often you can call it lying fine
sometimes I call it survival
okay
yeah I want you to make peace with Matt
so tell me tell me what we're what we're
doing you you've had you been thinking
about cross-dressing your whole life or
you have been and just hiding it from
people tell me more
yeah I I have been um
I I think it would help if I if I went
to the script I think it yeah just like
you said it paints a picture with
flowers um if you're cool with that
let's do it
um yeah so listening to your show made
me keep trauma that I previously
disregarded
and it made me feel compelled to take
the spcc aces quiz and I scored a 10.
um my brother hey can I just stop right
second stop
I'm so sorry
uh for a while I I I thought it was an
eight and so digging got me as a 10.
you just said that like you get a prize
there's no prize
yeah it depends how you cut the lines
around these things right yeah yeah
let's just say that
somebody that should have loved you and
taking care of you dragged you to hell
is that fair
yeah yeah and then you tried to get out
and they wouldn't let you
and uh they loved me the best they could
and they they were great I love them
still today stop stop defending them
stop
I don't even know what the deal is
the person I want you defending is
little bat
okay
yeah all right so tell me keep going
with me then what yeah
uh twice I want to attend my life and
once I tried okay
um I've sat down uh many bricks but
still carry some from the period yep I
said I was a liar that curated my story
I never felt comfortable telling those
around me about my cross-dressing which
was seldom expressed and very personal
at the time and once I did I lost any of
the people closest to me and it really
was a self-fulfilling prophecy that the
the thing that I was shut out for wasn't
necessarily the cross-dressing but the
the closure that that I was a walking
liar
words are theirs
theirs okay
um
I one example uh I had you know all the
groomsmen in my my wedding uh all but
one had known about me uh and then once
the that one last one did find out uh he
rallied the whole group against me and
then I was invited to one of their
weddings uh which which my wife and I
flew out to and I was threatened with
physical violence and I'd say I stared
it in the face I I stayed through the
party
um and
I don't I don't think I've quite set
that one down yet I I
miss them horribly
um and and I did catch on the last call
that that ability to try and soothe
others I felt like I was there for all
these people through a lot of their
darkest times a lot of the hardest
things for them and then just one one
whiff of who I am
um and and they all turn their backs
I'm sorry man
okay
so now we're through that the heavy
stuff but um hey we're not getting
through this for a long time I mean
I mean that
fear of abandonment
is one of the great human fears
one of the things that our we our bodies
we fake and we maneuver and we cheer and
rally I mean look at political rallies
there's no way all the people in those
things believe a hundred percent
but we're willing to go along with it
because of fear of Abandonment why
because true abandonment
feels like death
and you experience
really did feel like it yes
because that version of your life is
over
it's over the one that had where people
had your back and that y'all could tell
each other everything and you showed up
for each other at 2 30 in the morning
they left you
and here's why I keep here's what I want
to stay there for just one second
it's easy to point fingers and it's easy
to miss them but you gotta go through
grief you gotta sit in it
and it's your body's way of saying this
happened this was and that is no more
and I hate that you're feeling just I
hate your friends I'm sorry no I'm even
just hearing it from you saying that
that they they left you they were gone
um didn't breathe a huge shy of relief
it was kind of nice to hear it not from
someone else and not or from someone
else and not not trying to figure it out
yeah there's nothing to figure out man
when your friends abandon you to your
face
and let's go this far even if they're
right like let's came out and said hey
I'm having an affair with my with
somebody else's wife and this and that
and your friends are like I'm out of
here dude
that still hurts right
yeah or if you come out and say I'm
struggling with X or I've got this or
like any time your Rider dies look at
you and say
nope
and they're out
it's death it's devastating that old
life you had is now over and you got to
figure out how to ask what to do next
and if you have an Aces score of 10
often our friends become our families
they take on a larger than life role and
how we love and how we feel safe
and How We Do Life shoulder to shoulder
Andy Captain kneecap and
I don't know there's just something
profound parents leave family leaves all
right that sucks it's heartbreaking it's
hard all that
friends bail on us all right so tell me
about cross-dressing how long since
you're a little kid you're older tell me
about it
yeah since I was very little and it
happened intermittently
um kind of on and off for periods it was
something that I could always kind of
bury for for periods at a time
um and then let me ask you this and I'm
doing this
partly as educational for me because
you're teaching me and for the audience
okay so this isn't gratuitous
um
tell me about was it just
you felt a sense of Anxiety Relief by
just wearing
comfortable underwear or when people are
out of the house you had a stash of a
dress somewhere like tell me tell me
tell me what it looked like
yeah
um I think more curiosity at first like
early on I remember stealing some like
uh tool from the the Thanksgiving
display it was like a little material
and I'd like put that around myself as a
skirt and it was something that I'd done
by myself and then kind of hid away okay
and um
there were other times uh like at a
family event I found myself in in like a
Cosmetics drawer and saw uh like like
maxi pads and I didn't know what the
hell they were but it was just this this
intense curiosity for what it was
and then that evolved into when I was
I would say like Middle School into high
school age I I started um finding
articles of clothing that I could wear
on my own secretly that I'd hide away
and still somewhere in my yard there's a
hole that I buried like a skirt that I
was afraid someone would find
foreign
I'm just laughing at like some Farmer's
gonna be mowing his yard someday and be
like uh
um so was when you said I was like six
inches deep for real
so when you're talking about like
discreet you're talking about socks and
underwear no
um more like skirts I went to a private
school and there was there was uniforms
associated with it and so in the lost
and found I'd like found a skirt that I
could take with me or okay okay
so how is this is your does your wife
know yeah so that's one of the big
things I take solace is that the day she
met me I had my nails painted and
um we hit it off so great that day
and then that that night one of these
friends that ended up leaving me said
you gotta call her man she uh she thinks
you're uh you know the hard f word and
uh you got to set things right with her
and tell her that it was a joke or
something
and uh so I talked to her about it and
oh so when she met you she thought you
were gay
yeah um she didn't but but he said she
did yeah yeah okay right okay
right to kind of maybe protecting the
group I don't know what he was what his
plan was
um I'll pause here real quick because I
know this is gonna I can already see
where this is headed there's something
called um I just lost it what is it
called uh
fundamental attribution error you ever
heard me talk about that on the show
no it's when we get into somebody else's
head
and try to come up with a story as to
why they did what they did why they said
what they said what I would tell you is
fundamental attribution error is a
complete and utter waste of our time and
I would tell you stay out of people's
heads who cares like the guy I live
there the guy I know I know it does and
it's it's uh haunting It's haunting
because the stories you create are
always infinitely worse because you are
the always The Whipping Boy in those
stories
and it's hard to look at someone and be
like
even if I had been gay do I like
you're not gonna be my friend are you
gonna lie but you see what I'm saying
like it's hard to even go there and
challenge your friend it's easy just to
look in the mirror and be like I suck
which is what most of us do so stay out
of people's heads is what I'd say you
have enough going on inside of yours I'm
confident right
yeah I mean I mean that's so much the
core of what what ails me is is this
this living in people's heads and having
this dialogue that I'm finding more and
more isn't true that's right
that's right
it's disorienting okay so your uh your
wife knows right
yeah so she knew from the get-go
um and as our relationship grew so did
uh my expressions in it it was something
that we shared together and it wasn't
any anything that she ever tried to
restrict my expression but more just
made sure that I was
um
like let's say appropriate for the
weather or whatever the the situation
was or that I felt comfortable in my own
skin was important to her so so we all
have the same pictures and words when
you say expression are you talking about
um y'all would get together like for a
movie night and you might
um
wear women's clothing and you all
snuggle up on the couch and watch the
movie together are you talking about
y'all went to the movies out in public
and you went and had dinner together
um with you wearing women's clothing
both
as early on it was like very seldom
um that we would go out in public
um
and then that grew some and we became
more comfortable doing that okay and did
she um was she on heightened alert for
people double taking or was she like
whatever this is just my husband's
Wackadoo and it's all good because I
love him
yeah and I was always kind of high alert
in those early days just thinking that
there was going to be some outward act
of violence towards me or okay something
I didn't I didn't know what I expected
it so let me ask you this when you when
you
when you call it expression when you put
on women's clothing is it an anxiety
release as though you've identified
women's clothing as something that is
that is safe and relaxing and soft and
feminine what what is it about putting
on women's clothing
or are you in the process of considering
transition
a little column in a little column B
um I think there is like a safe bit of
it I don't
I don't consider that I'd go through any
medical procedures but even this
afternoon I got laser treatment to
remove some facial hair okay which hurts
like all because they shoot your face
with a laser yeah yeah yeah that's it's
pretty traumatic
um
but yeah
I have anxiety building and then it's
something that I do to relieve that
anxiety it's a relief okay um
but it's it's the contrary that I build
relationships and the the less that
people know that part about me and the
longer I know them the more
uh untrustworthy I feel okay
and and being outward about it I feel
like I I tear down that wall and that
people just get to see me as who I am
okay let me just say it this way I'm
gonna head directly into
this conversation in into like a I'm
gonna make a pretty direct statement and
I want you to hear me say it's a
statement I've been making for decades
across all different kinds of of
uh challenges people are experiencing
okay and so but I also know that by
making this statement it's a hot button
issue so I need to I need to know you
and I are on the same team on this is
that cool
yeah okay so when somebody calls my show
and they tell me I have anxiety
you've probably heard it I always tell
them you're experiencing anxiety
this is not
anxiety is not a core identity
and so when you tell me this is who I am
what I want to like I want to hug you
and say you are mad and this and this
and this
and I know that's very unpopular because
we've in our culture currently in this
in this little moment in history we have
braided together identity and who I am
and these things that make me feel safe
for these things that make me feel less
anxious or these make things that make
me feel a little more at peace see what
I'm saying
yeah and so what I'll tell you is like
you're my brother Matt
worthy of being loved and your body goes
when you put on women's clothing now I'm
open to being wrong there tell me if I'm
wrong or if that if that strikes a chord
with you
uh it definitely strikes the chord
um more process oriented but um
I I wouldn't say that you're you're
wrong it's it's just the general
behavior is
um things that I'd kind of
compartmentalized as being feminine for
fear of being found out um like taking
care of myself hygienically
um that kind of stuff I always just
pushed off or almost went to the Other
Extreme just to just to hide it so yes
yes and yes
I think that some of the things some
things are clearly labeled feminine and
masculine and I think anybody across any
Spectrum can look at it and go yeah
that's feminine masculine and there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that is it's
a lot grayer than we like to pretend it
is right
sure yeah
um okay so you've led me here what's
like the the question that's that's
sitting with you I'm sure you've got a
bunch of questions what's what's a big
one I could help you with today yeah so
my wife and I moved you know across the
country and it kind of came to a head
with the the birth of our child I
thought that it'd be like the last time
like I put it all away and and just kind
of man up all all at once and that'd be
the end of it and it was like the the
opposite
um and and I felt more more compulsion
than ever to to just make sure that
everyone knew especially my son I didn't
think I'm turning 18 on finding out
something about me or whatever age um I
didn't think that would be healthy for
him
um but that led us to her in my in-laws
her parents uh discussing moving out
across the country and heard you say not
by their hand but in their lap um they
have to deal with me in some capacity I
don't expect them to love and embrace me
open-handed
our open armed um but we did end up
having a conversation about it went
about as well as it could
um and I guess the the final Stones I'm
carrying on Final breaks I'm carrying
with them is
uh that the father said
um I'm not coming here to judge anyone
um but it's something that has to be
kept a secret from anyone you know back
where we're from and
it was over the course of the next few
days I've been living in an absolutely
wonderful life my wife and I are very in
love our child is healthy everything's
good we're baby steps millionaires we
nearly paid off our house we did all the
things to for me to feel like it could
finally express myself and uh
just being told like keep that to
yourself I don't know over the next few
days I
really just felt like I had to make
myself small again
um it went away almost immediately but
but that thought of making myself very
very small happened again and
I don't know why and because it's not
even something that I want to go back to
New York and express these things to all
these people it's
I just want to know they're in my corner
um so let me let me um is it okay if I
push on you a little bit
yeah please
um
I've
I've had I've had similar conversations
with people my whole career okay
particularly 18 to 22 year olds with the
students I was working with that were
coming to realizations of all kinds okay
and they would come some sometimes
stumbling into my office they didn't
want something to be true or they
finally wanted to say something out loud
and so
um
one thing I always told them
and again maybe I'm a wrong forsakeness
but I always told them
your parents get a minute
because
your parents have this picture that they
have had since the moment they found out
they were going to have you
and it was going to look like x y and z
and now that picture's different
and they just get a minute and they're
gonna say dumb things and they're gonna
say the wrong thing and they're going to
maybe in your father-in-law's case
he loves you and sees how well you take
care of his daughter
and he loves how much how good of a
father you are and he also knows that
he's got a bunch of bigoted idiot
friends or friends or whatever
back home
that will abandon him the way your
friends abandon you
and so there's some there's some place
for
compassion there's some place for
his whole picture's different now
and I always want to go on both sides of
the conversation now I've had plenty of
conversations with parents and
who've called me and said if I could do
anything in my life over again I would
have that first conversation back
right so
every this whole thing is so
so messy because people want to say what
they want to say but they don't know if
they're going to say it they don't want
to be bad but they also are like hey
this is weird I've never seen this or
this isn't weird but I feel all of it's
so messy and so just the best you're
able to having a spirit of Grace
I it it not only helps that person but
man it gives you peace right
absolutely is that fair yeah
I'd like to say I don't
you know I've been listening to you for
a bit none I don't feel like I've held
any resentment and that I'm you know
giving him Grace awesome um but that I
also don't feel that
they're um the mother may be more so but
I don't feel like it's an open
conversation or that it's something
that's Revisited and the door was kind
of shut okay and so I I never wanted to
be something so decorative but I didn't
want them to move across the country if
it was going to be an issue for them
um and I feel like like he doesn't quite
understand the extent like that it's
something that I can just hide entirely
and so I don't know how to keep that
door for conversation open with someone
that and I quote this he says there's
things that I will personally take to
the grave and this is also one of them
and so I I don't know how to talk to
someone like that
was a couple things to play here okay
first first thing here
any major change
any major change is going to affect the
relationship with people okay
that is
he is to decide
whether he wants to be in relationship
with his wife and
her husband and their baby
and you and your wife get to decide what
being in relationship with us is going
to look like for other people
here's what we're going to say is okay
here's what we're going to say is not
okay
here's what we're going to say is
offensive in our home here's what we're
going to say is not offensive in our
home
and here's what we're going to accept
here's what we're not going to accept
and then that's just called Boundaries
and then this is this is who we're going
to be this is how we're going to roll
this is what our life is going to be and
this is what you're experiencing is
something that statistically speaking
most people will never experience but
the principles apply to everybody
in our home these are our values this is
how we're going to be
and in-laws parents friends coaches
former professors whoever if you're
going to be in our life
then these are our values these are the
jokes that are not okay
This Is How We Do Thanksgiving
and then they get that they get that
choice
go ahead
yeah if I had to put a marker on what
the value is in this it's not that
anything is particularly offensive or
makes me feel bad I'm actually very okay
with with that but I would say my value
is that when you come into my home that
we have open conversation and we we
discuss the things those elephants so
maybe having that sitting down with the
your father-in-law and saying
the last conversation we said was that I
was something this was something you
were going to take to your grave
I need you to know this is something
that you will see and experience if
you're in my home
and then your father long is to decide
what he does next
I think that's it who do I pay
and here's the deal
you've spent your whole life making sure
other people are okay
that kept you from getting killed
so you still have an inclination to make
sure everybody around you is all right
and if you and I were sitting down and
we had longer to spend together
I would ask you or well I'll just ask
you here are you interested in you've
said several times like I wanted this
just to be done
was that a was that shame talking or is
that man I really
don't like the way this
compulsive Behavior builds up in me uh
shame and fear and since I've been
expressing myself more I get more
outward love from everyone in my across
communities
um
it's it's almost affirming Behavior
right and that's so that's some of the
the psychology that people come out
against
is that right now we're in a season when
it's it feels so good so many people
come up and high five you that it it all
it reinforces your body like ah I'm
extra safe right you see what I'm saying
sure yeah
so I guess I guess what I'll tell you is
man
you and your wife have to come to some
sort of agreement on here's who we are
and here's who we're going to be
and here's what's here's what we talk
about in our home and here's what we
don't talk about in our home
and then
like millions and millions and millions
of people you've got to decide are we
gonna let in law A and B come in our
house and make their political jokes and
complain about the food and whatever and
if we're just gonna do it for a weekend
that's fine
no they're great I love them I I I
really do feel the resolution in in
hearing just that that simple statement
to
to tell them hey last time we had the
discussion it seemed like something that
you might take to your grave but when
you're in our home it's something that
you might experience and be around
and I want you to know I love you guys
could not have asked for better in-laws
and
it's important to me in our house that
everybody is safe to talk
yeah and I mean it's great
and expect there to be pushback and
maybe maybe not but I would I would
expect that that sounds does that sound
fair
yeah 100 okay are you seeing somebody
for the anxiety I'm not I've seen people
over time uh for for periods this time
and then kind of float in and out I
guess covet kind of disrupted that it
for a bit okay
hold your little one
five months
here's what I can almost guarantee has
happened when your wife got pregnant
that the uh actually you said the
compulsion there
your body remembers
your body remembers the abuse your body
remembers the hurt your body remembers
the exclusion your body remembers all of
it
and it will recall those stories with
your little one that's why I'm so
hesitant to say like this is just me
versus this is how my body's trying to
stay safe
it's a way it releases this anxiety okay
here's what I'm telling you I believe
that I want you to go
sit with somebody who's good mental
health professional it's good
now hear me say I don't think you have a
mental health disorder because you enjoy
wearing women's clothes I think anyone
who says that's incorrect
I think you are
desperate to stop feeling so anxious all
the time is that fair
yeah okay
there's a guy who's gone through Seasons
when I couldn't breathe
being so anxious I can't breathe
and I try to solve it with a flurry of
activity both in my head and both in
action
and you get exhausted and I get
exhausted
I get low and the whole cycle repeats
again
someone should reach out to somebody and
say it's a new baby my childhood was
unfathomable
I want to have peace
for the first time in my life I want to
have peace
and I've laid a great Foundation I don't
anybody any money I've got family who
loves me I've got a ride or die wife
she even laughs at me she's great got a
kid who loves me a kid who's healthy
I'm ready to find peace Matt you are
worth that your little one's worth that
your wife is worth that
thank you for being brave thank you for
being courageous and saying these things
out loud I know this stuff's hard and
you had these these you've had this in
your soul for a long time thank you so
much you're uh willingness to have open
conversations is going to help a lot of
people
if I can ever help in any way holler at
me man hey uh send him a copy of own
your past change your future too hand on
the line Matt and Jenna's gonna get you
a copy of that for free on me and um
give it a read and let me know what you
think